you know what it is La icon right here
on my boy Rich Homie Quan repping the
food Community we're right here at
bootleg kev's podcast our episodes out
now
great cat podcast special guest here man
we got uh two guests well the the makeup
of the fumunity Foo Community I was
gonna say it's not food Community right
absolutely not school Community the
original Community The Who Community
podcast if you guys don't know Foo
Community is a great Instagram page
that's ran by the guy who's off camera
introduce yourself what's up
Rich Homie won they call you yes sir
okay so this is the guy he does not show
his face
for a bunch of different reasons I'm
sure well what's the main reason you're
um Anonymous he's ugly
I'm just kidding now if there's any way
I can make money without you know being
out there in the Limelight I'd much
rather take that I respect that you
respect your privacy yeah because you
don't want to be like you know people
running up on you feeling some type of
way because you guys post stuff from
everywhere yeah an icon gets it yeah he
lets me take all those Strays so you get
all the thing I'm made of Teflon so you
get all the like Flack because there was
like a wasn't there a Mexican rapper
list that you were posting like guys I
didn't come up with this I just gave it
I posted my own list you had a list that
you posted right top 40 list
and was Mexican OT number one yep yes
sir number one it wasn't even on the
list no yeah he was number one we agreed
on that we both agreed on that yeah so
what was for you give me the do you
remember your top five uh it was uh
Mexican OT at One D baby at two oh Jeezy
at three
money signs and peso at five not bad
valid list I mean yeah obviously suede's
not with us pesos are incarcerated but
they're definitely on Route he was on
Route while incarcerated 100 percent
so it's safe to say Texas
in terms of the Latin rappers is kind of
running it right now one and two
I would say so H-Town and I'm a Cali
full you are a Canada and I'll give
Texas you agree
I had otl1 I had Chito Rana said two I
had is that the guy who was with uh
Swifty for a little bit okay
uh who did I have at number three I
think I had D baby or oh geez oh yeah I
had D baby and oh Jeezy tied at number
three
who did I have a number four
um
I don't feel like scrolling but yeah
something like that but you get Flack
for his list nice absolutely nice he's
compensated well so it's got to be kind
of cool to have somebody to be like the
face
you're like yo yo I need you to host
this podcast it sounds like a great idea
but then you get all the right because
it is what it is what would you say for
you man like starting this IG page what
year did the page initially start uh
December 28 2018. damn sick anniversary
day that was the day December 28th right
after you got an iPhone for Christmas
and you decided to make a page or what
no it was just a thought it was just a
thought I would have follow a lot of
food pages on my personal account
and uh but no everybody was just posting
memes they'd have like 100k followers
but they were making money now I'm like
damn like if I had that many followers
I'd run it up so it was just a thought
for like a month and then one day I was
just high and I'm like you know what
[__] it I'm gonna just make the page and
I did it and then ever since then it's
just been going crazy it's been going
crazy what is like for you if I think a
lot of people don't when they see an
Instagram page with a lot of followers
they don't necessarily understand the
business model on how to run it up right
so like if somebody like you said you
saw people who were making memes and
you're like man they're not doing what
they're supposed to be doing what are
the things that you know set up the
business for food Community outside of
the podcast which is a newer thing
obviously is it like paid post
advertising yeah most of it almost all
of it is advertisement okay yep so for
art like
because I think there's some pages we'll
see nowadays that used to be like
I think for example like academics like
academics page I feel like a lot of like
major labels kind of have to like they
kind of have to pay them like to promote
like for you though like are you is it
like half and half or because because
you're are you posting that you're not
necessarily feeling and if you are what
is the what is the caption is it are
y'all feeling this or not or oh I have
my own captions blasted or trash it gas
or pass okay you know I have my own
little catchy sayings so if somebody if
it's someone pays and you're like this
might not be
crazy good I'm Gonna Leave It to the
comments but you can't because you're
yeah no I definitely don't know yeah you
shouldn't they're paying you
exactly so if I'm a rapper
from Albuquerque and I want to get on
food community
not to watch your pockets I drop a music
video got a cool little trailer I want
to get it all food Community shoot the
cash out shoot the cash out PayPal
that's what does that cost
song sucks I'm terrible oh no no if it's
no even if I'm not feeling it it's still
the same price I'm not gonna tax you
more because I feel like the song is
better or worse I mean the price stays
the same
equal opportunity yeah
okay how much is the post did you say
500 page on story post and there's that
to stay up yeah it's permanent oh that's
good that's solid right I mean for the
following that we have yeah how many
files you guys got uh
308k as of now that's good so you're
running it up you're eating yeah I know
we're good yeah and with that money I
was able to fund the podcast we got the
studio
and then uh
over half the money we just invest back
into the business that's smart yeah so
for you you bring this guy along uh you
needed a host he's obviously been doing
a really good job of producing content
for your wife indicted to me and then uh
you're on no jumper yeah doing the news
and such have you done some interviews
on there too right yeah it's in a couple
interviews uh what made you bring icon
in icon was uh I just felt like he was
already tapped in with the scene he was
a videographer he already knew all the
artists especially in the Latin Market
in LA right so he was already tapped in
and I needed someone who knows or in
each and icon just fit the description
and I feel like he was a perfect fit
what is your I'm not too hip to like I
know you're like you've been around La
for a long time but icon give me kind of
like your background
so I was from a hip-hop group Once Upon
a Time called The Campaign we had our
[__] hosted by Julio G Tony G
some of our projects um I've been
filming music videos the entire time uh
the very first time I synced the music
to the [__] camera footage was uh
J-Rock and glasses Malone and L boy
video
uh back in the day have you heard alboy
pretty cool Latin wrapper uh and yeah
ever since I've been shooting music
videos and I did the rap [__] I
eventually got signed a brown side have
you heard of brown side I've heard of
brownside when they made the Resurgence
I was shooting their music videos they
decided some one day that they wanted me
to continue rapping for them and I was
like [__] it so you used to be a rapper
see I didn't know there used to be a
rapper yeah so you were I intend on
coming up here and dropping a freestyle
and [__] on all your favorite
artists oh you're about to rap not today
are you gonna get back into it uh
oh well because I'm up I should
capitalize and drop music at [__] my
late 30s
why not uh I'm definitely gonna we're
gonna do a cipher series and I'm
definitely gonna drop the first one
would be like big tick you know like how
TIG would respect that I respect that
narrative hey coming rap I'm gonna drop
a freestyle you know it's fire you know
not bad I like that idea why don't you
do that I can't rap you're you're a
rapper fool you I heard the project you
got a gold plaque in there with your
name on it yeah no bad I didn't rap no
wrapping here sir
if I could rap I probably still wouldn't
I like it I'm 36.
you know here's what it is
um so but where what what area of uh I'm
from east L.A I'm from El Sereno to be
exact okay
did you come up like because I feel like
you're uh you didn't have any graffiti
[__] in your background or am I tripping
I mean everyone that was a gang member
tagged at one point right I suppose
that's that's the case yeah I'm not
gonna disclose all of that right now but
yeah
and a legend gang member yeah of course
of course I'm a good guy you're a great
guy
um so you end up kind of having like a
turning your music career into being the
video guy which is that went hand in
hand because I had an Empire deal like
12 years ago ah so you already was
rocking with gazi early early
I was rocking with my homie cavie but
yeah essentially yeah that's crazy dude
so you were shooting videos and putting
out music at the same time and for a
while it was cool and then when I
started doing the brown side [__] I got
a little bit more popular so I kind of
took a baby step back and then the owner
of my record label got assassinated in
Mexico that's like a well-documented
thing if you look up poker brownside
it's like a thing and when that happened
I just decided like he was the the glue
over there so when he died I had just
released my album and I thought it would
be like a scummy thing to do to like
capitalize on the notoriety we got from
his death so I just
broke off just did my own show yeah I'll
just continue with the video why'd they
kill him
I don't know exactly but they definitely
it was definitely really rough they uh
abducted them from his home in front of
his wife and kid and uh
they shot him several times and they put
him on the side of the road in Mexico so
what years would you say where you're
like Peak rapping like years just so I
can kind of get engaged and what like
2012 to maybe 2017. okay so yeah that's
not long ago dude it's not that long ago
yeah so for you like what made you kind
of like go all in on the content and
like you want to know what it's kind of
weird how that happened to be quite
honest because I started doing like a
little podcast with my boy called the
sauce and um when I was doing that I
looked at my wife and my wife has a
pretty Dynamic story and I was like
I think we're gonna make you tell your
story not on my podcast I gave her her
own [__] so from one day to the next I I
built a set or whatever I mean it's not
that crazy just prison clothes right so
I hit up all my homies nobody it's a
clean set because I didn't know that
that was your wife because I've seen her
stuff pop up no yeah it's pretty it's I
don't want to say it's super viral but
it's definitely a widespread
so um yeah from one day to the next she
did a time in prison she did uh she did
five on a RICO Act she got federally
indicted on the RICO Act did you know
her prior to that or did you I had met
her did I no I didn't know her that was
in 2008 when she got Rico indicted okay
I had met her maybe like around 2012.
through one of my buddies from the from
the group
it was like they're from wherever
they're from in Northeast L.A it's a
popular gang over there and
um she just showed up to be like an
extra in a music video we were doing
like a liquor store robbery she was like
one of the patrons of the liquor store
and now my girl was there at the time
she pulled up just oh hi bye whatever
cool cordial [__] and then yeah your
other girl your previous girl
[Music]
I ain't mad at him man so then you
executive produce her [__] and then
another show right uh executive produced
her [__] and then I helped produce the
food community and obviously I'm the
host the foo Community [__] what for you
like obviously doing a podcast I I was
telling you this like I think it's like
an obvious like you guys are feeling a a
niche like you said like there really
isn't like a Latin hip-hop podcast in
terms of like I mean if there is like
I'm not like super hip so I could be
yeah
no that was the goal too when the food
Community was started I know there was a
boy there wasn't really nothing for us
and um that's something I was wanting to
do I always wanted to help put my people
on and I knew it was something that was
needed for you obviously the biggest
full Pages Fool's gone wild right these
guys have sold out the novo they've
toured it's amazing it's it's crazy
right The Branding it's wild do you guys
have any sort of rivalry going going on
or is it like all kosher like nah nah
nah there's a lot of full Pages by the
way oh for sure I would think that
there's nothing at all really it's just
they they cater to a certain uh they
they produce certain type of content
which is you know funny [__] yeah it's
funny I've even sent post over there
shit's hilarious but we're what we do is
more like news and documenting music
stuff that revolves around the culture
things of that nature they're very much
like common or I think a Fool's going on
I think a comedy you know what I'm
saying yeah
uh I gotta ask you guys this because
we're talking about this a little bit
before what do you guys think about the
peso pluma thing did he end up canceling
his shows he absolutely did cancel his
shows that's the smartest thing he could
have did because for people who don't
know was it the new Jalisco cartel
threatened to essentially kill him yes
if he did a show in Tijuana yeah uh
Arena Stadium that's a hard ass Arena
too yeah
I've driven by a bunch I haven't been
inside
um but I didn't I you know because the
way that they put the message up imagine
okay so there's like he was saying when
we were off camera there's Chalino
Sanchez he got past a note he opened the
notes said don't sing the [__] song
you want to sing or you're gonna get got
he sang the song and he got God so I
think that's a pretty good example being
sent for you to just kind of maybe
follow instructions you know what I'm
saying if you're him though do you like
not do Mexico shows now
oh like at all what I'm surprised this
is that someone just doesn't address it
directly like someone he ha he's super
famous he has to have some somebody
behind him somewhere some friend that
could be like damn maybe we should reach
out and try and iron that [__] out
because imagine you're missing a whole
[__] demographic isn't he from their
area kind of I'm not sure if he's like I
don't know I don't know if he's a town
he's from is no no no no no well the new
Jalisco cartel is not from TJ no but the
show that that happened the show that
the main show that they told him not to
do was the TJ Show right yeah yeah but I
don't think they're from I don't think
that's necessary I mean I'm definitely
not going to get into the politics but I
was going to say like uh they're
everywhere bro but that's what I was
gonna say like he didn't even
necessarily say anything bad about them
it was the fact he was big enough El
Chapo right and El Chapo's son in his
music I'm not exactly sure but that
seems like a a dope narrative to run
with yes well he makes songs about you
know certain cartel members who that
particular group of threatened peso
pluma
um have issues yes
crazy
if I'm him I'm like guys
Mexico's out it's not worth it fool it's
not worth it why are we even gonna do
Mexico like not even Cancun my boy just
did the VMAs yeah first Mexican to
perform at the VMAs I killed it killed
it it was dope absolutely it was dope
that's did you guys see Dojo cat walk
out and basil plume was just like I
didn't
what do you think about Doja cat's
transformation to the dark side I mean I
think I just think she's I think that I
think she's dead [__] serious Kev
about being a Satanist yes no yes no no
shaving your eyebrows getting tattoos
this is the one thing if you if so so
okay so the one thing I've heard about
Doja cat and I've interviewed her a
bunch and she's always been like she is
the most like dry humored she gets off
on like people like thinking she's weird
this is like her like if you ever saw it
that's her thing but did you ever see
any of the like clips of her like on
webcam like in like these webcam groups
she'd be in oh yeah you saw that I've
heard of the [__] right it's like
she's got like a dark humor and my you
know my boy Casey clearly recorded her
very early on and would always say the
same [__] like she's [__] hilarious
like she
I think she knows what she's doing and I
think like and you think she's gaining
more followers and fans followers no
yeah so I mean how how good of a plan is
it then she doesn't give a [__]
you shat on all her fans she said I
don't know you [__] I don't owe
you guys [__] I mean I recall that
actual statement and she lost I think
she lost like a hundred thousand
followers the next day and the thing is
is with this Satan [__] she's losing
followers
but who gives a [__] like it ain't even
Satan's [__] she has a song called
demons so she [__] did like a horror
movie
ask video back tight but her whole IG is
dedicated to like being bald and having
no eyebrows no she's doing like a little
creepy [__] she's being she's trolling
that's a [__] crazy troll bro that's
leaning all the way in but what is she
posting on IG that's that makes you
think she's leaning in she'll have like
pictures of herself covered in blood
like just weird she she took a picture
because in in that video you saw her
dancers were all bloody so she said look
I Met Myself because she put a statue up
in New York of her covered in blood were
y'all saying the same [__] when DMX was
in a blood-filled bathtub
it's dark in hell it's hot my boy I'm
just asking he Praises that was Flesh on
My Flesh Blood on my blood by the way
but he also openly admitted to selling
his soul to the devil did he
yeah I saw my soul to the devil but the
price was cheap
you look at belly the opening scene the
opening scene of belly it has a small
version of Tommy buns drawing a [__]
pentagram and selling his soul to the
devil
it's like yeah everybody I just got
educated I just got educated that was
fire I didn't know that DMX DMX is great
one of my favorites rip so I got the
belly poster right there
classic yeah listen what I say like Doja
cat to me is artistically probably like
one of the most I think her music is
incredible I think she can do anything
she can make pop music she can rap and
if you like this that demons video
whatever you want to say about it I
haven't even seen it but I'm gonna watch
it now that [__] is the best video of
the Year by far fire it's like a high
it's like a horror movie it's a movie so
my thing is is like she's just producing
theatrical content and people are taking
it literally
because she's not an actress she's an
artist but if she was acting in you know
[__]
The Exorcist or some [__] people
wouldn't be valid yeah yeah so it's like
yo she's just really defending Dojo I
think she's incredible what would you
say to the conspiracy theorists who say
oh well you know they're pushing an
agenda so-called you don't believe in
that no no these people are [__]
retards God bless them believe that
please he's part of that agenda I can
tell no I'm just kidding no look this is
what I'm saying this is what I'm saying
I do think I do like well in terms of
the entertainment industry pushing
certain agendas
narratives narratives narratives I mean
yeah everyone's got a narrative to push
everybody an agenda's deep as [__] what
I'm saying an agenda is what he said so
to me like narrative is one thing like
you could push a narrative you should
you could push your narrative huh
everybody's got a narrative to push
about themselves you know what I'm
saying like I think that the agenda [__]
where people are like well the music
industry is pushing Satan into our kids
lives and it's like dude this is one
nothing new
facts guess what I just bought a [__]
Metallica T-shirt with the devil on the
front of it
all right I respect it Alice Cooper bit
the head off of a [__] bat was it no
Alice Coop
it was Ozzy and then Ozzy pissed on the
Alamo right I was pissed on the Alamos
Alice Cooper that did that no Ozzy
Osbourne he's banned from San Antonio
what the [__] did Gene Simmons do or he
just stuck out his tongue Ozzy did the
bat yeah
you understand like bro
first of all I'm sure you guys are
religious I'm not
I'm very are you agnostic yeah I'd say
I'm agnostic um
agnostic believes that there's something
atheists don't believe in [__] right
correct I don't know so my whole thing
with religion is like I've done enough
like uh psychedelics to like think that
there's probably like a whole lot we
just don't know about so my whole thing
is just I don't know
you know I think you need to do DMT
again
I've never done this oh yeah that's
right in the store you never did it yeah
I'd like to I'm scared though I want to
do it the right way so I want to do it
like with the [__] crack pipe you
know let's do it here together right now
by the way well what we're talking about
the before we go on a tangent about
drugs
um no so if you think about
like right now right you look at Playboy
cardi you look at Uzi with the upside
down crosses you look at Doja cat like
people can be like yo this is even if
it's even if religion doesn't exist per
se let's just give you this but listen
though let me finish my thought in 1998
I watched Marilyn Manson perform while
ripping Pages out of the Bible
Blasphemous okay in the 80s dude there
were like metal bands that like were
openly [__] just like
anti-god they had but like dude if you
look at Megadeth and just some of the
imagery
like this is just it's [__] rock and
roll bro
like it is what it is like if you look
at Playboy cardi like Playboy card is
saying some crazy [__] but what if like
God does exist and all these fools are
gonna burn in hell that's on them
that's on them but what a crazy what are
the odds what are the odds
[__] I don't know none of us do
and the thing is is like what are they
actually doing what about the meaning
behind what they're doing they're still
putting a lot of intention behind some
[__] what's the intention
disrespect towards
what people believe to be good
you know a belly it was a rapper he has
a belly's Fire by my favorite rappers
ever he has a line where he says hero
villain it's all perspective
I respect it what's good to one person
is not good to another person right like
to me like if you really want to get
into like the religion talk like I don't
but yeah yeah but 99 of the major Wars
that have ever been caused are because
religious are religious based facts I
mean the Catholic church has covered up
the biggest pedophile ring of all time
that's documented it's facts facts are
fast it's like it's like which way you
want to go with it you know what I'm
saying like yes there are people who are
pushing like satanic imagery but I don't
think it's in a literal way you can't be
like okay I understand what you're
saying about like the the the priest
touching the kids [__] but those are the
people not the cause yeah but the cause
covered it up oh nasty I feel it they
did they moved these [__]
around
so my whole thing is like
what's good because to me it's like I'm
not a Satanist but if you actually look
at like the [__] people who are
say they're satanists they're really not
satanists they're for sure gonna say
you're saying this afternoon no no but
but if you actually like see the the
like I think it's there's there's two
versions of the Church of Satan I don't
know there's no a lot I do have it
I've watched YouTube videos so there's
two versions there's like these Dives
there's like the side that is just like
we believe in like having fun we believe
in like partying and [__] around
exactly vicious and then there's like
the more literal side but they're
separate churches from what I understand
I don't know I'll let you tell it but
I'm not into you know I'm hey dog I like
doing mushrooms I believe aliens are
real that's what I believe what'd you
think about the aliens that just got
unveiled in Mexico you know I thought
pretty cool
I had heard somebody had said that the
guy who's behind revealing these bodies
had already kind of tried to do the same
thing maybe 10 years ago or something
and it was like a hoax but I don't know
if someone's trying to run a [__]
hoax on us in 2023 we could
scientifically fact that she fact check
that [__] like cracked the glass on that
[__] see if it's the craziest [__] is
that [__] that happened in uh Vegas with
that family that Mexican family explain
you didn't know what happened you didn't
hear what happened in Vegas was like two
months ago where there was
there was like beings in their backyard
and they called the cops and the cops
pulled up and they saw them whoa and
it's on body camera footage where is
this bro it was everywhere pull it up on
the TV sir yeah
listen send me the link send me the link
this isn't Joe Rogan we don't have Jamie
we got Cyrus Cyrus is fire [__] Jamie no
I'm just kidding not yeah so there was
like a family in uh Vegas that uh they
said that something landed in their
backyard and then when they went outside
there was like two beans in their
backyard it's in Vegas like a pro-gun
state how come they just didn't give
them the [__] business that's
breaking and entering as far as Vegas
Nevada I used to live there Nevada is a
I don't know they're kind of in
somewhere in the middle they're kind of
like a little more liberal than Arizona
but you can buy some [__] there not in
Vegas
not in Clark County what's that the
ranch you're talking about going to the
ranch well I'm saying like Vegas is
Nevada is like a pretty like excuse me
for being a conservative state-ish you
could buy [__] there so I don't know
how conservative that is it's pretty
conservative wouldn't you say buying
[__]
yeah
have you ever purchased [__] in Nevada
never
you look disgusted when you said that
never now have I ever slept with a woman
whose [__] was for sale without paying
her in Nevada quite possibly got it for
free yeah I mean I used to [__] around
with some Morgan like this is the home
girls on Vegas when I lived there this
was like 12 years ago so you befriended
[__]
maybe I like it yeah I respect it yeah
nonetheless how do we get to this we're
talking about peso pluma to Doja cat
[__] happens man you deflected away from
the peso pluma and I want to talk about
this [__] Castle Plumas a smart man
let's end it there do you guys think
he's like
on his way to being like the goat
Mexican artist ever because I've never
seen a artist doing like that kind of
music trans like like he just did the
VMAs like we talked about that shit's
crazy can I say I think go ahead go
ahead buddy I would say so I mean he's
already breaking records that no Mexican
artist has done he was the first one to
perform at the VMAs he's the first one
to chart on the Spotify
um
what is it chart glove with the global
chart yeah oh yeah he's a gentleman uh
not just educated us on the Hot 100 hot
200 best billboard yeah oh that's right
that's right that's right
um I want to say that before him there
was someone that's very big and still is
and that's so that's right Jesus Ortiz I
was about to say from
even isn't job before them too before
not that two or same time uh I think
he's the guy that paved the way they're
I mean no I'm saying like maybe there's
people who paved the way for sure but
yeah as of right now this guy's like
[__] those guys on fire he
transcended just people in Mexico
listening to him no that's valid like I
was in the club in Vegas and I told my
guy
who's DJ and Sam I was like Hey play
that [__] what's the word what's the
record he's got with the group it's like
the big right the the record
who um
no really I have no idea I don't I just
don't listen to him oh okay he's cool
he's up I congratulate him he's not for
you
uh my wife listens to him I don't even
listen to music Kev let's be real who do
you listen to your podcast
I listen to Snoop Dogg and Dr Dre and
Tupac fool okay can't be getting
brainwashed by these young kids and
their agendas and their agendas
uh yeah not it's just crazy because I've
never seen it before I'm just like damn
this [__] said the VMAs this was
up but also we gotta consider that
he's in a he's popping at a unique time
so like in five years or ten years from
now based on the way media is moving
someone else is going to probably be
even grander what do you do you guys
know what the moment was or the thing
that kind of changed the
Direction me and him were actually
talking like he was like I'm gonna say
what you said this who said he was an
industry plant I was like nah
I mean it seems like he just blew up
like one but I was telling him you know
concrete yeah of course okay so concrete
uses shoe videos yeah YouTube videos for
the guy what's he doing he shot videos
for best okay
yeah I'm picking up so he shot videos
for peso pluma before he was who he is
now right so I mean if concrete's
shooting your videos I'm not sure you're
an industry plan because that means you
kind of grind it you know what I'm
saying do you find concrete that means
you're on the grind I mean there's
definitely a machine behind them he
didn't just [__] find Director X and
just and he also has like an like Bobby
D does all his shows that's not the
[__] big machine
we could go to Prague right now you want
to go visit where they've recorded [__]
at it's like this it's nice it's out
here I'm just saying it's not [__]
Paramount Studios is he out here yeah
well I'm not sure where best what part
of Mexico I'm not sure but prahin
Studios is in [__] Anaheim or
Santa Ana or some [__]
I've been there it's a cool place cool
place but I'm saying it's not like crazy
machine Warner Brothers right
what about uh Latin hip-hop as somebody
who obviously participated as an artist
what are you gonna ask me who's the
biggest no no I was gonna ask what do
you think
has kind of been the biggest thing
that's held back like let's just say
Mexican rappers I can't call it because
I want to say that um in my time King
little G who is still thriving you know
what I'm saying I want to say King
little G is the biggest artist that made
it the furthest out of all of us and I'm
not exactly sure why he didn't break
through the ceiling I mean he had a fish
feature with Nipsey at his Peak Nipsey
was obviously nipsy as Nipsey right so I
mean you figured that would have got
spun and you're in radio how come that
[__] didn't get spun what's your opinion
on that you know better than me you have
a way better Insight on that than me I
just know what my look well you're an
Insider I'm asking you what you're what
are you what are your what is your
hypothesis I feel like we weren't around
for the Paola times and if we were we'd
be up already nah there's some of y'all
were around for them times Little Rob
and he has some classic radio hits
he does Summer Nights great record but
not yeah I don't I actually I actually
have no idea why the industry hasn't
really um picked up on too many
landmarks so my thing is like a lot of
the bigger like I think the one thing
that's still about the Texas guys is
that they're just making music and they
happen to be Mexican as to where I feel
like
when I was growing up a lot of the
Mexican artists were just like so overly
like chocolate out where it was like you
kind of had to be around those type of
people or be those people to really
connect with the music there's a cap to
that there's like that generic music
fans you're gonna be like well little G
doesn't I mean initially he had a
particular look now he just looks normal
got some big ass chains where's Versace
what's the difference
yeah I mean I don't know man I just
think you know at the end of the day
like radio's not the difference is what
I'll tell you and then uh what money
sign Suede and money sign sway got
signed to Atlantic so he was on his way
yeah I don't think Atlantic's the best
label for
I mean they they didn't know what to do
with cab G they didn't know what to do
with money signed suede he probably
smoked a blunt with their girlfriend
I got [__] no I'm just kidding but I
think that is one thing about the guys
from Texas is like it's just rap it's
not like Chicago like if you just threw
on Johnny Dang and you didn't see how
fired yeah like who who OT was you would
just be like oh this shit's hard who is
this guy and then you're like oh this
guy's holding a [__] chicken with a
cowboy hat this is wild I mean you know
as opposed to like if you just saw a
picture of that maybe you'd be like this
shit's not for me like the music is is
to me more palatable for everybody
exactly if that makes sense no yeah I
respect it it's also a different time
different time for sure for sure hey
what up we gotta stop the interview to
tell you about our folks and my bookie
that's right now look
I'm a big Gambler love gambling love
sports gambling I have been on a tear
look I ain't gonna lie to y'all NFL
season so far been real good to your boy
you could get down go to mybookie.ag
sign up right now with that promo code
bootleg and uh you know what's great
about that promo code is it's going to
get you hooked up with uh 50 or more
your first deposit you can get up to 200
in cash straight to your my bookie
account with the promo code bootleg at
the end of the day Aaron Rodgers season
is a wrap my guy tore his Achilles it's
over your season doesn't have to be over
NFL college ball man the new cash out
system on my book is crazy let's say you
got a three leg par leg a four leg
parlay maybe three of the four legs have
hit and you're waiting maybe on Monday
Night Football to see if you hit all
four but you don't want to take that
risk you just want to cash out take your
money and run you can do it that brand
new cash out system is fire alright so
make sure you go to mybookie right now
man so much to do all kinds of daily
odds boosters same game parlays huge
prize pool contest right now
mybookie.ag all right sign up use the
promo code bootleg on your first deposit
of 50 or more you can get up to 200 in
cash instantly to gamble with plus we
got a shout out to our fam at
blue chew that's right this is a good
thing about Bluetooth guys
well one you know the one thing I always
get asked about Bluetooth is one does it
work
two do you use it well yes on both
Accords all right shout out to Bluetooth
it works but you gotta that not take my
word for it get a whole month for free
right now if you go to bluetooth.com and
use that promo code bootleg they're
gonna send you a month's supply of
Bluetooth straight to your door for free
just gotta pay five dollars shipping
same active ingredient as Viagra and
Cialis and when I tell you that your
dick is going to be [__] your Johnson
is going to be johnsoning
your [__] is going to be rocked up
socked up and ready to unload yeah it's
like Barry Bonds seven he was a 73 home
runs 70 home run season you're gonna be
knocking them [__] right over the
[__] ho what's what's the Big Green
Monster in Fenway Park [__] your dick's
gonna be hitting hitting that [__]
straight over that wall you know what
I'm saying or whatever you're into you
know they don't gotta be [__] you could
be [__] whatever you're into
bluetooth.com put your best foot forward
when it comes to your dick all right you
don't want to go on a first date with a
young lady who you think is you know
easy enough to [__] on the first date
and not be prepared get the Bluetooth
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg and get
your first month for free same active
ingredient as Viagra Cialis no awkward
doctor's appointment uh it's all online
discreet packaging straight to your door
in a chewable Forum bluetooth.com promo
code bootleg let's get back to the
interview where'd you guys have Swifty
blue ranked
he didn't make the list he didn't make
your list for 2023 no really
wow did he feel some type of way
I don't know he feels like the kind of
guy that would feel some type of way I
mean is he respectfully I mean is he out
there because of his music or because of
the headlines that he makes
we had a song with Kodak Black right
that was last year
I mean
um
that that list was for 2023. how many
people were on the list 40. so you think
there's 40 rappers hotter than Swifty
blue respectfully yes musically that are
doing maybe more I didn't even
contribute to the list but I get it
really yes
I mean I have to stay tapped in with
who's up and coming oh let me see I
Gotta See Sam hold on let me look at
this list are we gonna look at the
Spotify numbers cross reference yes I
respect it
because I just think 40
. Swift y blue what would you rank them
I feel like Swifty Blues got to be a top
20 guy I'm surprised you feel like that
because I interviewed him after your
interview and he uh oh yeah me and him
are fine though I could imagine that
whole interview was an interesting uh I
saw I had to interview him after to help
him [__] rehab His image
yeah I try to not drop it and he kind of
pressed me to drop it vicious I
literally told I gotta I mean I told
Rosecrans Vic I said hey dude this may
might not be the one let's rerun it yeah
and then Swifty had reached out and was
like yo don't waste my [__] time I
was like I put it out but I mean me and
Swifty had talked a few times
um would you say it's kind of been
downhill ever since that interview
a lot of people after that interview
things got bigger for him huh
I feel like the the checking in thing
became a thing yeah
that [__] was great okay people still
say it to this day what's the where's
the list at is it just so is it pinned
yeah it's been
like yes it's number one
okay number 40. damn you got him at 40
huh yes who's 40. crook
crook one just got a [__] he's the
first Mexican with a deal with at
Zoomies
I think CNG should be higher for sure I
said that as well actually yeah he was
in my top ten I think CNG should be
higher than over who
you put CNG on the top ten Rich greedy's
the guy from San Antonio yeah
I think cng's he's not on Twitter right
now headlining I don't think a lot of
these guys can go do a solo tour like
let like like nobody like he just did a
whole show and he just did a show at the
Nile in Arizona last week and I think it
was sold out try to tell your ass
to be fair though like I'm not sure like
Rich greedy can go in on a tour
and sell tickets Richmond is the best
Mexican rapper in San Antonio
okay he's like and what yeah I just
think CNG at 20 is crazy I just feel
like he had a better album Casablanca
than cngs
um
I'm not hip to everybody so I only sit
here and act like I'm [__]
like I don't know who uh aceto is
who's oh Northern California rapper yeah
I'm a hip I gotta check him out yeah
it's pretty hard
I didn't know who some of those people I
just don't know like like my thing is I
put sad boy much I put sad boy in the
top why is peso number five
over who
okay so uh he's not putting now
win win last year this year earlier this
year
months ago months ago or Get Rich or Die
was it 2023 or 2022 2023 okay okay from
jail
okay
technology is a crazy thing I think and
his fan base is just too strong I get I
think I mean even even like if you're
gonna like like I think yellow Hills got
to be higher because he's just put out
so much music
yeah I think I would put yellow Hill
over Phoenix flexing
um
I would
did we talk [__] to Yellow Hill about
not dropping anything this year when he
came up here or well up there no no no
no no no yet because he said he didn't
respect the top 40 list why is on here
she's not a rapper
that's what I told him she's a singer
she raps sometimes she's a singer
I'm telling you she shouldn't be on here
no one cared about my contributions to
the list and My reasonings I put sad boy
in the top ten because he's the only
person out of that list that's charted
tell them what happened in this last
show though when did he charge [__]
you're stupid what happened nothing went
well
what the [__]
uh Swifty Blues what I can you don't
like not Swift to school Swifty's fine I
talk with him on a back then on a couple
occasions back then all right so Swifty
blue has 137 000 monthly listeners um
let me just go to somebody on this list
and there's no disrespect to whoever I'm
about to pull up because I don't know
everybody on this list
I don't let's look up young eggs
where's that person from
um Modesto 24 000 monthly listeners this
is 2023 though mine juice 50 Blue's been
around for what five years okay okay
well I listen hold on let's see what how
much music Swifty Blues dropped this
year
because he just dropped a new single
with T Fly
he dropped the record with Cyprus
he dropped the car he dropped you're
advocating really [__] harder I know
I used to have two projects this year
did he yeah I just think it's I just
think like I just think y'all crazy
Blue's not he's top 40 bro he's top 40.
he has to be 40. I definitely respect
your opinion and guys don't blame me
it's the staff's list I made my
contributions was he in your list uh I
only made a top 13. I didn't make it to
40. nice so your top 13 was
damn and they only respected like three
picks which three
actually I'm not even sure oh uh money
uh peso Mexican OT D baby oh Jeezy but
not necessarily my order so
um do you feel like because I had CNG in
my top I had I just think it's crazy the
cngs I had drummer he's doing [__] that
a lot of these guys ahead of him can't
do I respect it yeah I try to put him in
my top Andy's got a dope album
damn you guys have CNG on the show yet
no we gotta make it happen we're trying
it's easy
have you talked to him
um
you talked to the sour apple right or
publicist okay sour apple had him coming
up and for whatever reason they had to
reschedule and we just haven't received
maybe because they pulled up to where
your guys's Studio's at and we're like
they're like
you know there's a little fentanyl party
going on on the corner I like it you got
the guy grilling right that was fire hey
you want to know what yesterday I
thought I saw them selling drugs but he
wasn't selling drugs he was selling beer
and I can't imagine him having a better
price pick I can't imagine having a
better price than the [__] store so I
was just in Portland for like two days
and then you know everything's legal
there
God damn dude still not worse than
downtown L.A
everything's legal in Portland like you
can do heroin in front of the car well
they do hair in front of the cops here
but like it's officially every drug is
decriminalized in Portland when you when
you were walking up to sue didn't they
like blow crack smoke in your face or
something like that and then we were
dodging uh we almost stepped in [__] and
puke remember that vicious you stopped
me from stepping in it you're like bro
watch out I was like oh [__]
that was sick gnarly ass [__] uh anyway
um who do you guys think is like kind of
like
somebody who's not on the list who you
think is talented who you guys can like
kind of see having like coyotes work
even on the [__] list
coyotes that's what I'm saying so
coyotes didn't make the list I think
they definitely should have been on
there they just dropped a record with
[__] Shaq diesel I didn't even think
about it vicious they should be top 40.
uh Snow the Product should have been on
that list but I guess once upon a time
she told the staff that she never wanted
to be mentioned on the food Community
again so she just got it blacklisted no
she didn't get blacklisted she just
doesn't want to be mentioned but I think
she deserves to be on the top 10 for
sure no [__] yeah it's [__] Snow the
Product no [__] I didn't even think
about that yeah what happened there I
mean the thing is this did you post
something that she didn't like uh she
made a post about on her podcast
um I don't want to get into it but she
was like clowning men and we had to pick
it up I saw it on tick tock and then she
said hey I don't like the comments that
people make about me I just don't want
to be posted I'd appreciate it
well
that's why she's on the list
well the thing is if we're gonna
say it buddy I mean if we're gonna no
never mind
your faces are on camera get it out get
that disrespect out yeah there's no
disrespect I don't got no I don't got no
animosity towards her what are you guys
what about baby gas isn't he Mexican uh
yeah he is but not top boarding
respectfully okay
I'm just asking yeah yeah I [__] with
guys he's an honorable mention yeah he's
cool
it's a very why you know hey
you got your list there are some people
on that list I even question like who
the [__] is this me too
and then I looked at a couple of them
I'm like ah
if we're going to be giving love to
up-and-coming artists that are actually
like making big strides and I could see
it but like there are a gang of
legendary people that
were left off maybe not even legendary
but just people of stature that could
have been on the list that weren't
or different places what is the
the [__] qualifications
um so impact numbers
um
just all around
next year you got a Lexus on that list
you got like a hundred thousand monthly
listeners is he a rapper or a singer
yeah a little bit of both but you got
[__] J rocks on the list who sings
her heart out she's on tour at MC Magic
sings her heart out
she sings her heart out I didn't put her
on the list respectfully she's very
talented she's dope didn't she just get
into some sort of like a wasn't there
some sort of controversy with her
recently yeah with 44 about them what
was it
I think she said something around
um that there's no what was it icon that
I don't [__] oh that there's no like
super pop pop and they got on her
because Selena Becky G right right no
that's what it was yeah yeah Becky G's
[__] huge of course Becky G's a
legend she's from L.A
yeah
who what about you who do you think is
like uh
will you say well we both you guys say
coyote I said coyotes I said uh who else
did I say I don't know snow
who else uh
damn Alexis should have been on the list
you're right
next year
at least I know we didn't get up here
because of favoritism right of course
I think it's dope because it creates you
know creates uh dialogue well everyone
don't have their own opinion not
everybody's gonna be pleased for sure
and then a lot of people too are stuck
in their own bubble too A lot of people
stuck in the LA scene so what about this
guy and then I really tapped into the
Texas scene or up north or Florida I'm
gonna say for you like you're like like
do you think people look at Food
Community as a la biased platform
clearly it's not now I feel like the
reason they try to say that is because
we're sending the wrong Latinos and La
just happens to be the most populated
Latino city in America I'm just talking
about interns are like because you've
done interviews off camera with people
from Northern California and you said
you won't do uh certain interviews right
well I just sit out some you'll sit out
some I'm sick you're sick yeah I got an
ailment I would I mean anybody's more
than welcome but I was feeling good
today so I made it yeah not anybody's
more than welcome it's just uh some
people just don't want to come to LA
some are so you have to go up there yeah
so I have to go up there and if that's
what it takes and that's because
politics for whatever reason yeah yeah
is it do you guys feel like because you
know in La hip-hop
um you'll see a lot of the gang [__] get
in the way of like certain people
working together even though they might
want to work together or you know like
sometimes the politics over the last
like 20 years has kind of like affected
maybe like the direction of the
unification in La hip-hop kind of moving
in the same direction rather
um do you guys feel like that that's the
case at all in the Latin Community with
the North side or south side or [__] at
all
everyone can make their own decisions
you know what I'm saying is just
you know what it is
what I'm saying it definitely slows down
the money for everybody yeah that's my
thing is like you know what I'm saying
like if it feels like there's like
there's artists from Northern California
but they're not going to work with
certain artists from Southern California
even though they don't necessarily have
problems with each other and it's like
hmm do you think Texas is gets wrapped
up in any of that I don't think so no no
they kind of got their own thing going
on right
that's Texas is on fire they got one and
two on the list no Texas is going crazy
yeah yeah [__] Texas is I mean you got
the guy from San Antonio above CNG
I mean check them out no I've checked
them out you can rap yeah he's cool
Kitty tour
CNG top 20. that's crazy it's gonna be
top 13. I put them in my list he was
number nine on my list what's next for
you guys you guys gonna start doing live
shows you guys are going to try to start
doing any sort of like are you gonna
ever step behind the camera and let
people see what the [__] you look like
no probably not uh what's next well
thanks for trying to throw a food
Community presents event will you be
there uh yeah I'll be there but like
where in the cut we have like a [__]
mask on it could be blending no no what
does he need to mask on if no one knows
he [__] looks like are you gonna wear
your [__] Big C chain uh I'll
probably be wearing that I should be
wearing it right now
I can see it
so that way they know there's two of us
here what were you doing before food
Community bro if you don't mind me
asking that was a barber oh [__] cutting
hair getting all fades nice not
licensable now everyone wants one and
she's not there to give up you're not a
licensed Barber no I was still at a shop
though
oh [__] so you were still you were like
an actual Barber yeah and I was actual
barber in the shop
once would you quit the barber work uh
once the food Community took off you
were like [__] this which was well no
actually it uh we had to stop cutting
hair in the pandemic so like April 2020
so I was just in the house and then food
Community blew up around that time
because everybody was just on their
phone right and then I quit barbering in
June that's when I had enough money to
just quit and do it full-time that's
[__] sick man ever since then ever
since June 2020. so were you like
passionate about you know some people
really I've hosted Barber battles like
[__] that shit's a whole thing
yeah yeah like people really get into
the barber [__] bro I was passionate but
then it kind of just died down you let
people do designs under your hair no no
no no I no my boy owns a bunch of barber
shops in Arizona so he does this AZ
Barber battle and I host it every year
what's the name of the homies shop
what's the name of uh swish it's uh
you're partial to a lot of people named
Swift that's amazing
the shop were always out with mosh
[__]
I don't [__] know dude where what
it's on Bethany
I don't know the name are you from
Arizona as well
everybody's from Arizona not me if
they're with me dang showing love to his
freaking Arizona from San Bernardino
though damn dirty Dino in the building
grew up in Arizona
how would we moved to Arizona
cap I I did I moved back and forth when
I was five
he's from Arizona I think so too his
baby Mama's in Arizona
you're a [__] [__] why'd you have
to disclose that he don't even have kids
I'm [__] he's [__] dick anyway hey
we gotta stop the interview to tell you
about our partners at Odd Socks baby
that's right shout out to our family at
Odd Socks man look the most comfortable
socks in the entire world
odd Sox official .com they just got the
Coca-Cola license they got the Scarface
license they got the WWE license they
got [__] Kool-Aid socks Chucky you
know what I'm saying Halloween's coming
get them [__] Chucky socks speaking
of Halloween what about the Ghostbuster
joints man oh these are gas they even
got the Ghostbuster underwear what I'm
trying to tell you is whatever you're
into they got them at Odd Socks
oddsocksofficial.com they just locked in
the brand new uh saving uh uh what's it
called
um
well look they got Transformers and
Power Rangers that's essentially what
I'm trying oh Hasbro the Hasbro license
all right they got all the socks draws
all that [__] plus they got The Odd
Socks Basics which are my favorite just
the normal guys I mean I wear them every
single day of my life they're literally
the most comfortable socks and don't
forget about the underwear ladies and
gentlemen the underwear there if you
want to get 20 off at checkout go to
oddsocksofficial.com use that promo code
bootleg 20 off at checkout odd
socksofficial.com
trust me all right you go with some of
these Odd Socks you put them on if they
ain't the most comfortable socks you
ever put on your [__] life you
know what I'm saying DM me I'm not gonna
reply but they because you're a liar
yeah I mean anyway also want to give a
big shout out to our family at King Palm
baby that's right shout out to King Palm
man listen I've been smoking these King
Palms since they've come on board and I
don't know what man look bruh
these things right here
it's a tobacco-free leaf
just organic no no like uh no [__]
you know I'm saying just organic
I mean this thing right here this like
it's it's natural what I like about it
you know what I'm saying now this is
what I like about King Palms is I went
from smoking just straight papers to
strictly King Palms and I love it
because I like the way they burn and I
like the way they taste because what
they do have are these terpene flavor
tips yes they're infused on the tip
tobacco-free you squeeze the tip
and it's a burst of flavor these are the
sugar punches shout out to Sugar Shawn
O'Malley uh these are the dragon fruits
right here we got grape they got all
kinds of flavors I mean literally
watermelon they got an energy drink
flavor California cream whatever it is
and check this out right now not only
can you go and get King Palm at your
favorite smoke shop by your house maybe
7-Eleven pop in get you some King Palm
whatever smoke shop is near you has King
Palms liquor stores all that but you can
also go to the website and get 50 off
half off whatever you want to order from
King Palm they got the smoking
accessories the ashtrays the Grinders I
mean the glass tips whatever you're into
kingpom.com promo code bootleg say 50
off at checkout shout out to King Palm
man I'm about to smoke up right now
after this podcast all right yo let's
get back to the interview
um all right so so uh it's a food
Community type Festival yes that would
be hard we're also adding a gang of more
uh oh we're trying to have sex first
ciphers you guys getting out some music
we're trying to release an album project
we're currently talking Empire Loki
that's hard you guys uh it's not okay
anymore uh are you guys you guys
obviously got the new segment that you
just started right we're doing the news
we're doing music reviews we're about a
spotter start a sports segment that I'm
not going to be involved in because I
don't know [__] about sports anymore
should I have more segments on the
channel me and my wife have a little
show that we're gonna do called the Ike
and Tina show oh fire
Spotify playlist it's about the message
no I'm just kidding we got a domestic
violence show
are you guys really gonna do a show
called icon it's literally out first
episode oh really we need to drop it's
doing almost it's you know how you can
see your inside it's competing with
fluffy right now we're going up oh you
guys had had the fluffy interview coming
that was amazing
directly simple [__] yeah just do DM you
dm'd him and he said I'm down yeah he
said I'm down get out and get out my
assistant and then took about a month to
schedule that was that like the one
interview you guys got where he was like
yo this is [__] crazy this is crazy
yeah bro it's so [__] crazy the other
day someone or I think last night people
were talking [__] on a podcast saying
that we were going down their list
taking their guess and I was like I
don't think you've interlaid interviewed
bootleg cover fluffy or Jimmy or Jimmy
humility or Jenny 69 or you guys have
interviewed like the top of the top the
creme de La Creme I'm sure how dare you
[__] compare us
disrespectful you still working a no
jumper does Adam feel some type of way
that you host a different podcast
someone loves me like his favorite
brother oh no I'm just kidding Adam
doesn't give a [__] about anything
[Laughter]
oh God damn he doesn't care about
anything they were at work fool they
were at work man
they were at work and I don't mean like
a work Affair like they were there at
work yeah for sure you have a strong
opinion on that go ahead let it out no I
don't give a [__] I tell everybody like
why are you guys surprised these guys
have been [__] other people on camera
for how long and now it's like a dude
who cares
they're very nice people double standard
I always say that though I'm like you
guys are [__] how many women if if
somebody came to me and said Mama I'm
gonna say this on camera
I respect it you know what I was gonna
say I don't know anything you're married
I'm married
shout out to my wife
there would be no no amount of women
that my wife could let me [__] to let
her [__] one guy except for like 500. if
she was like you could [__] 500 [__]
and I won't get mad that's a lot of
[__] I might
that's a different [__] every day I
feel like Adam might be up in that
number oh for sure so at what point in
time is it like
it's not a bad trade
I can [__] all these women and then you
can [__] one dude
yeah
not bad
would you do that uh absolutely not fair
enough but I'm also not in that racket
so I don't see it that crazy for that
for us for you or I to do that that's
[__] Wild
but like I said they were at work it is
what it is they're like literal
professional sex performers this is
facts yeah
how much of like what you've learned
being around them are you helping like
Implement with the food one thing I
could say Adam is one of the most
knowledgeable podcast people I've ever
come across I've been privileged to sit
in a couple of table meetings with him
at no jumper and
I soak it all in yeah and be cap if I
said no I don't haven't learned [__]
from no jumper of course I learned
everything from no jumper that I do in
podcasting the camera [__] setup I'm
[__] yeah I still man nah you guys are
killing it dude I'm just not gonna bomb
other [__] with my wife on camera I
respect it that type of [__] don't rub
off on you no no I'm not that
impressionable I respect soaking in
knowledge versus getting it you know
getting your crazy vices yeah oh you're
a [__] Wild guy don't disrespect my
homie like that Gene I'm just [__]
around
um what about um foreign
who's been the guest that you're like
you really like you got fluffy that's a
big one you just had MC Magic on right
yep that's coming soon yeah you just had
magic doing backflips and Skid Row fire
yeah and he thought I couldn't do 20
push-ups you barely got there I saw this
oh I did it
if you wanna have a push-up contest
right now and I will yes I win is that
facts I guarantee you I'll beat you in a
push-up contest just flex your alarm
real quick I need to see your tricep nah
just go you don't need to see anything
I'm scared let's put money down 100
100 bucks that I can't do how many we'll
go till we stopped nah
I'm just at like you know for you would
just be like crazy to get like
man like uh like a rock bar Bossa would
be fire yo he I think that's two I mean
I've dm'd him he's he's he hits back
have you reached out to him yeah he
follows us yeah dude I recently spoke to
someone that is related to someone in
his team or some [__] they're like you
guys should get Ralph on and I was like
yeah we should I'm shooting for the
Stars even like a peso Bloom I would be
fire [__] yeah I try to get besso pluma
through his record label his producer
that produced like five [__] songs
some of them are the one of them is a
hit
and he was like yeah I don't know gee I
was like disrespectful damn you were
friends damn I'm trying to get Cheech
right now
buyer he just did uh the dope is yellow
[__] dope as Yola is the biggest weed
podcaster in the world though isn't he
yeah [__] Andy's up he's killing it
I've interviewed would be a good one
burner agreed we just need a you know
he's just so busy honestly you guys will
probably have to go up there
sounds fine down from there yeah I love
the bear I think that's super doable
burner's probably not coming to your
spot though she would enjoy it I'm not
saying he wouldn't enjoy it but the
likeliness of like that busy
[__] like coming together
MC Magic caught a [__] uh no magic
will come out here to do it he did and
he left the same day he was like you got
what you guys want to do and I was like
I gotta take my ass back home Jesus let
me just fly back homie fools ain't no
fun I was like all right [__] it yeah
yeah no magic drove when we he did our
[__] I mean I've interviewed Magic
we know we know you have a long
documented history yeah he drove out him
and Jay rocks drove out and they did it
together she was cool Jay rocks is
coming next Thursday ah there you go
peso plume would be the one though right
that'd be tight dude we're gonna see
what happens we gotta get Swifty blue
one
talk about their list
see if he's available where's that
yo I don't know man I'm just
not into your guys's niche as much as
you guys are um
because I don't know all the people on
this list I know a lot of them but I
just think that you know a lot of people
he's hot like you know maybe I'm wrong
could be wrong
you would know more than me though
literally that's exactly like that's
exactly what him and the staff told me
we know more than you and I was like how
about how how deep is the staff it's six
of us six oh wow that's good not
including me
so so what is so so for people like you
have people who post on your page
they don't necessarily have to live in
L.A or do they live in Illinois they
don't have to live in L.A so are you
always hiring uh not as of now
it's been months see amen if someone
leaves then yeah we got to get someone
else
six why you want to be an admin or what
no
[__] around can't do it what am I
supposed to do Drive some narratives
that you believe in throw some Alexis
posts in there yeah I do that for sure
anyway well look I appreciate you guys
pulling up
um go watch the YouTube channel you guys
got a bunch of dope interviews I just
did an interview recently Fluffy's on
there the MC Magic interview's dropping
soon it might be out by the time you
guys watch it what's the next interview
that drops actually like releasing we
have a yellow interview I'm dropping
soon yellow Hill okay he's dope fire
he's cool and he's cool in real life
dude sickest dude nicest dude [__]
records here it works for my producer
he's so nice nah yellow Hill interview
we got uh the only Mexican Diamond
dealer in Los Angeles maybe in
California that episode's coming out
that's sick where he's actually busting
down these live
oh is he like doing the test that no
[__] the test these are real for sure
I'm talking about actually placing the
Diamonds oh it was a thing did he make
those yeah he made them wow
wow yeah let me get you one man get you
one
um you need to get some bootleg cabins
and who else we got we got yellow hill
we got MC Magic we got did we already
drop ears bullshitting
um who else man we got like probably 12
in the vault right now yeah we got it
more or less
you guys are booming man well
congratulations well thank you
appreciate it how many days a week are
you doing the news every day every week
I mean just once every Tuesday once
every Tuesday see if that grows to maybe
Tuesday and Thursday I don't know no man
well you guys are definitely killing it
go follow them online uh there's two
food Community pages right there's only
one there's only one is it but don't you
collab with the page yeah we have a
music page a news page and then we have
our backup page but the main one is at
Food Community right there's a backup
page have you guys ever had your [__]
taken down you had to get it back yeah
that's why we had to get a backup just
in case he lost your [__] I will five
yeah like we got like two backups no but
when you lost your first page how much
you lose it at oh four
416 okay oh my God yeah what's wrong you
got the plug at Instagram for us to get
back that old page and combine what is
the old page full community with the the
food Community oh
wow that's the OG page shoot the plug
Kev I know you got it my boy hey
Empire's got the plug you guys are
talking to Empire facts they help me get
my [__] together I think maybe we'll
settle for the second or third offer
they give us and I have that in because
I had an issue with my Ig and uh
they're like flag some [__] and then
they took away my blue check
what the [__]
back for something
and so I reached out you didn't have
enough Google images or some [__] now I
got flagged for like bullying or some
[__] I could see it yeah
but I don't even know what I I forget
what someone reported something I said
about uh
Paul George
um who plays for the Clippers I posted
oh you were on your sports [__] yeah
dissing and some weenie I know who it is
too some weenie influencers like that's
not cool and I got [__] he flagged it
he reported bullying because I said
there was a sign at a restaurant in
Phoenix where they said Paul George is a
[__] damn and I just screenshotted it
and reposted it yeah that's online
bullying my boy is spreading crazy nerds
they took my [__] blue check
and uh the homie at Empire uh you know
he's one of the main guys who handles
all their like correspondence with those
companies he got it back quick damn
shoot me his plug I mean you're about to
be sorry we gotta we got a plug it's
just once you [__] up so many times I
mean it's just that what was it but now
we're kind of good with not not knowing
what's supposed like what do you like
know like what do you not post because
you know oh we definitely don't post
anything that's any drugs no weed no no
sensors everything for everything
everything there's no sexual content if
it is getting blurred out hey it's smart
though man because that's your bag yeah
dog once you lose that almost a half a
million followers you're like [__] that
no no chances no words you can't say
stuff like that one of the staff members
literally
took down a podcast post and said tell
one of your editors icon to freaking
censor the word fight or censor I was
like what
on YouTube or on Instagram on Instagram
even YouTube's tough right now yeah is
it yeah oh man I got it down pack then
let's love
YouTube there I mean you you see like
Adam [__] he'll censor all the cuss
words out oh as far as oh yeah for sure
making sure every single cuss word is
not every single but the f word dude
I think it's not even that anymore no I
just threw on through I make sure
there's no F words I just did an
interview with with Gorilla names and
like dude the first like 10 minutes of
that interview we just did
we're talking about doing [__]
Academy and like all kind of crazy [__]
you love talking about drugs Kevin yeah
I like drugs I grew up around trucks
drugs are good do you like drugs it
sounds like OT LT loves drugs no yeah me
and him had a good time oh but you guys
did drugs together no no we had a good
time doing our podcast
we had a mean uh we went influencing the
youth we smoked weed together a lot
that's just weed and then I took him to
get Armenian food shout out to my boy
God smoke I'll lay I'm gonna bring him
up here next time and give you a gang of
free ass weed bomb
I feel like if anybody has any sort of
cloud in La they get a gang of free ass
weed my I don't want to disclose too
much but I got you I'll take all the
free weed all the free weed I get you're
gonna have to post some though [__]
ain't that free hmm it ain't bad free
actually the light post I could post
them I don't have a my weed sponsor
anymore I wouldn't I don't even post
stuff that's to do I have hardine
Harding's my dispensary in Vegas that
sells that's yours no no but this is my
dog I thought that was tequila this
whole time oh hardine is a dispensary in
Las Vegas the first was it the first big
one right I mean it's like the nicest I
thought it was like a plan on there no I
thought it was the first one no so we
had a sponsor
uh of a we uh that would sponsor our
freestyles that but they're no longer
sponsoring our free stuff I'm gonna tell
me I'm gonna call him right now yeah
we'll we'll talk about that off camera
do they sponsor food community no why
not because this food doesn't want to
weed sponsors I'll take him
we'll take them on YouTube
give me the weed
sick asphalt all the cash is green baby
anyway appreciate you guys for pulling
up man highly appreciate it uh what's
your IG so people can follow at La icon
at indicted TV at Food community
community at Food Community official at
Food Community Music actual Community
podcast and if it's up to him you'll
never know what he looks like at the
food Community News and at Rich Homie
133 underscore promoting the personal
page okay yes sir you got the little men
in black little thingy so that way we
can Flash Theseus so
I used to have one of those really it
was a pen as a kid fire anyway all right
there it is man food Community
appreciate y'all pulling up shout out to
the homie Savvy a r for the trenches
baby you know what it is Boom hey what
up man uh you just watched another
episode of the bootleg cab podcast
brought to you by hard Dean baby shout
out to the family at hardean don't
forget
make sure if you're in Las Vegas you get
into that taxi as soon as you land you
get into that Uber say take me to
hardine all right they're gonna take get
you taken care of the most craziest
Premium Selection of cannabis you'll
ever find Under One Roof it's a vibe in
there the bud tenders they gonna take
care of you man listen tell them I sent
you they're gonna get you right shout
out to the family at hardine in Las
Vegas the number one dispensary in the
world all right and we are so proud to
be partners with them so shout out to
hardine go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas and check out their
website hardinglasvegas.com get you some
swag you know you can't buy this but you
know yeah shout out to hardine